no longer simply fiances as i officially
pronounce you
husband and wife and natalie you may
kiss your husband
these two took us on a damn ride after
dealing with more drama
in three months than most people have in
their lifetime
mike and natalie officially tied the
knot when mike
finally said i do
i just started to breeze i feel like
oh i cannot believe girl we can't either
but congratulations i guess
congratulations we're going to take a
look inside their special day
plus e.t can confirm that mike and
natalie
will be on the upcoming season of
happily ever after
with angela michael kalani oswellu and
the whole
gang so yep i hate to break it to you
but
this ride continues also harris
might not be as big of a snake as we
thought still a snake just
not as big during this episode stephanie
got the blessing from harris's baby mama
to move forward with his k1 visa but
while stephanie thinks he's coming for
love
harris is now clearly admitting that
it's all about the opportunity
for him my mama that i can make better
life for them
plus my baby mother emma it's only one
time in a
history you get a good break like that
is harris wrong for doing whatever it
takes to give his family a better life
even if it goes as far as conning
stephanie
we're gonna talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissa
all right we have made it to the final
regular episode
of this season which means sunday kicks
off part one of the two-part tell-all
finale
so let's go ahead and get into how a
nice little bow
was wrapped on natalie and mike's
tumultuous
i couldn't find a better word tumultuous
season
today's birthday of my visa i don't know
what's happening today but looks like um
we're preparing for our ceremony
the situation is like unusual
last night michael had decided that he
wanted to marry me on my 90th day
if it was his way he would just stay in
the relationship with me
for some longer period without marrying
all of this just makes me question
if our wedding will actually happen and
all of this just makes me question her
true intentions for wanting to marry
mike
i mean at this point she's making it
easy to believe that she has ulterior
motives
why else would you still want to marry
someone who you know
doesn't want to marry you anyway
natalie seemed visibly shaken as she was
getting dressed
nothing can make me feel better except
seeing michael
saying i do she even got a little snappy
with tamara
you're beautiful oh
rude but honestly i wouldn't hold that
against her
she was terrified in that moment
if mike changes his mind again if that
happens
we are done forever
philip oh my god
although their ceremony was last minute
and didn't have any glitz or glam
i thought it turned out beautifully
natalie wore a dress
she brought with her from ukraine as she
held a bouquet of hand-picked flowers
it was simple and about the basics
which is what they need the officiant
was
also the same lady who natalie called
crying
after mike cancelled their wedding just
days before
my confession she's mine
okay slow down cause i can't i can't
understand what you're saying
slow down i'm sorry i love how she added
this little piece into her script
to help them out a bit well love's a
beautiful thing when two people come
together as one
so remember forgiveness is the best form
of love
it takes a strong person to say sorry
and even a stronger person
to forgive who's gonna be the stronger
person
that's the question here well
forgiveness
was definitely in the air because after
they said i do
you would have never thought that only
72 hours before
mike was asking natalie for the ring
back and natalie
was convinced she would never speak to
mike again
it was also really interesting to see
the way everyone else was acting
it reminded me of moments when i've had
a friend
make a really dumb decision and although
i knew it was dumb
i still felt the need to be supportive
you know
supportive and positive when i know they
had no business doing what they did
no longer simply fiances as i officially
pronounce you
husband and wife and natalie you make us
your husband
[Music]
i think they'll be just fine they'll be
fine
well mike and kelly got married they
tried to not
and i was so excited you know i even
said it to you
and i hardly ever do that but yeah i
didn't think they were gonna really do
it you know i had my
doubts but they did it you know and i'm
happy for them
and it's awesome i guess no one wanted
to spoil the party
given the fact that mike and natalie
both look so happy
what comes next well we're going to do a
little partying
yeah then then
later on tonight's uh yeah rock this
joint
the trailer is blocking yeah
[Laughter]
yeah that baby they're gonna be coming
next time was the time not the first 24
hours
through the next 48.
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right speaking of happy endings
harris
is trying to create one of his own this
man has no shame in admitting that he
wants to marry stephanie
just so he can get to america and create
a better life for his family
and while what he's doing is clearly
wrong
i don't know if i can be mad at it well
to be honest
i was always thinking that i could be
the one to be with stephanie
so i can move from here and go over to
united states
my kids my mom my dad i can make better
life for them
plus my baby mother emma because she's
my baby mother we live together 14 years
i love her so much
and i will always take care of her
harris went on to say that he's never
met
anyone in his life that would give him
free money
so he feels special that he met
stephanie he also added that this is a
once in a lifetime opportunity for him
and his family meanwhile stephanie is in
michigan
talking to her cat about how harris is
the one
so guess what my remember how mama was
telling you about ryan
he's gone he's not gonna be your daddy
but guess what you'd like harris
mommy's seeing somebody new do you want
to call
you want to call and say hi to harris
let's call harris
that was weird yeah what's even more
unusual
is how stephanie has harris's name saved
in her phone
harris dot dot dot fiance
what is she serious in this moment
harris is living with the mother of his
kids emma
who according to stephanie through text
messages
has given her blessing for harris to
move to the u.s
but now stephanie wants to hear it from
emma's mouth
all right i gotta hand over this one to
her
hi how are you emma
i'm good and you what would you ever do
if harris came here on ibiza
would you ever consider that even while
the children are young
well like i just came to walk across
there to make a better life for the kids
i will hundred percent support him
because i know he will not forget his
kids here stephanie also asked emma if
she's moved on from harris
and emma responded by saying that
they've learned they're better off as
friends but this kiss on the beach
didn't look like just friends
so i'm thinking emma is in on this game
plan with harris
it's such a sticky situation
because on one hand it seems wrong to be
using stephanie
but then on the other hand stephanie
acts like she wants to be used
she's a successful nice-looking woman
with a maserati parked in her driveway
she can find a man in america who is on
her level
but instead she chooses to date young
men
in a third world country who are
understandably looking for a better life
and then she throws money at him like
she wants to be their savior
so it's really hard to say whether
harris is wrong for taking advantage of
this opportunity
a part of me feels like i can't judge
because
i've never been in harris's position i
couldn't even imagine what it's like
being in his position
but i also know that you reap what you
sow
and manipulating someone else for your
own gain
never turns out well in the end i
love harris he is definitely
the man that i've been looking for hi
lucky so harris and i
are going to apply for the k1 visa
and i think that we can be my happily
ever after
you want to give him a kiss
oh baby oh stephanie stephanie stephanie
all right as i mentioned earlier the
first part of the tell-all is this
sunday
so hopefully we figure out where these
two stand
pretty soon in the meantime make sure
you stick with et
because as usual we are covering it all
i'll see you next time
you